[Music]
so we're gonna now try and delve into
some you know into the from the
strategic and the end of the career to
kind of the really you guys are you
don't know it it doesn't feel like it
but your earlier in your careers I can
attest to how old you can get and more
to go so so we're gonna delve into
really what it's like to run a company
and some some tactics and things that
have helped you be successful along the
way I'll introduce you briefly but the
BIOS were distributed and so I'm not
going to go into into detail we'll turn
to questions with 15 minutes left so
that's going to be at about 10 15 more
or less and then and then we'll wrap up
by 10:30 if not before if you if you run
out of questions and result une really
did a self-funded search he had a bit of
a career before he bought his company
and he invested a fair amount of his own
money in the search so though so that's
the wrinkle in it he he bought a company
in New York that is in the health
healthcare service businesses and I I
thought it was just a silly thing to do
or at least I didn't I didn't think it
was a great deal and I talked to Andrew
and and but I passed on the deal that I
said that did I say don't invest so so
you know from my deep experience in
health care services which which
actually was extensive then and and he
went on to return what was the what was
the multiple ID for your first investors
ten times ten times like that yeah more
than ten times is what he's saying so so
yeah so he did that there's an investor
clapping in the room I also was not in
Chris Hendrickson steel but that's
because I was already in a competitive
company he his partner bought a personal
emergency response services business
transformed it and focused it with with
really regional governments and then has
expanded it to provide further
monitoring services and really invented
a whole new way of monitoring high-risk
patients often called frequent flyers
the people who go back into the hospital
a lot and Chris also had an exit and
what was the multiple on on your exit
just nine we didn't quite catch up the
in charge yeah so that's why we're going
like in this direction
I think you know it's it's hard not to
pick on Butchie too but but he can pick
on you back so Tony is is is different
in here and we were thrilled to have him
here because he has a different path he
he is at assure Ian now and and he is
the next CEO of ensure cherie and he's
been he's been designated as that name
does that earned that and he so he has
become a leader in a different way by
learning from others but also very
intentionally developing himself along
the way so he has a different
perspective on on leadership and leading
team so that's we're happy to have you
here and you know if you you know can
you tell us a little bit about your most
recent posting before you before you're
taking this job I'm springing this on
you a little bit but when you're running
running part of the part of each area
yeah before my current assignment I ran
Japan as a region for the company which
is 300 million it's a billion in revenue
program it was an interesting experience
to learn I'm obviously not Japanese so
it was an interesting evolution of
learning a culture and learning how to
deal with people who may approach
business in some ways similar and in
some ways different but it was a great
learning experience and I think it
helped it helped just generally from a
leadership perspective
Raphael then coach Ito did a search fund
but couldn't find a company to buy so
started one in in Puerto Rico and then
after becoming an investor for a while
became evidence of a length of career in
the search fund community that you can
have by by then starting a new company
called qmc and could you give us some
idea of the scale of qmc today Treece
it's working yeah we're in four
countries Puerto Rico Brazil Mexico and
Colombia either two separate legal
entities and the International part
we're now close to fourteen hundred
towers in all three countries and in
three verticals about 150 employees and
continue to crank and how many of your
original search investors you know are
involved also in qnc
our lead investor which was Housatonic
in her first deal was also our lead
investor in the cell tower business the
group that original group most of the
people are both in a deal and then we
expanded that a bit it's it's been a
very long-term relationship not only
with my business partner and co-founder
who I've been partners with for twenty
years but also on the investor side the
same people that back this the first
time decided to back is the second time
around so I mean you were you were a CEO
an entrepreneur for in search then you
were an investor and then you did I
don't know if it's really a search the
second time around but a start-up
entrepreneur again when I did my company
I thought I would find the company buy
it run it for five years sell it and
then go on and and get involved in a
venture back to company because to me
that was sort I'd then I have the
experience to go into venture and really
this has been a community that I've been
part of that's it just keeps recycling
the same great people and the same
relationships and building on those for
you know for 25 years now so it's
alright yeah 20 to 28 years now so it's
those of you who are younger and in your
first part of your career and just
looking for that first success you
realized that it's really just a it's a
you're on a great ladder and a great in
a great group of people so we have some
questions since some topics here and
I'll just tell you what the topics are
and then we'll delve into them a little
bit so first we wanted to talk about
really human resources strategy really
people and how it ties to business
strategy and particularly I'm building a
team then we're gonna touch a little bit
if we get to it on how to develop
yourself as a CEO how to how you all
have thought about becoming better
leaders and how you've done that well
after you you know got your noses above
water and you're in your companies and
then lastly we'll talk a little bit
about scaling people systems and
processes and I've heard that that was
I've heard that a number of times with
people first and then the and then the
processes and then the and then the
technology to support and and automate
those processes so we'll talk about
scaling that and how each of you has
scaled your organizations because you've
reached some scale that many here would
like to get to so any of you can answer
but don't feel like you
all need to answer I would like you
answer this first one which is we just
talked about the team you inherited when
you bought the company or when you took
over your organization or pick a point
of because you started from nothing you
started from scratch pick a point when
you were at an inflection point of
growth in the company so talk about the
team you inherited and then how that
evolved over the course of say the first
five years of your business Andrew so
when we bought the business in 2011 the
company had 12 employees and the CEO
part of the reason he was selling was
that he felt like he had just a ton of
direct reports and couldn't manage it in
our first year we probably let go eight
of those 12 and then hired in another 15
ish employees and then just to give a
sense of what transpired from there
forward when we exited the business we
had about 150 employees four years later
and felt like we had developed a senior
executive team a little bit of middle
management and a lot of team members and
in the beginning we didn't have any of
that it was just kind of me in twelve
direct reports we had about 40 people
when we bought the business and I would
say it was very task-oriented I mean we
had we had a team of 40 there was no
managers and leave there were titles but
nobody really managed or led anything it
was all task oriented and I think as we
as the business grew we kind of went
through a few phases I think right away
we did hire for tasks and for function I
mean we needed someone who could do
finance so we had to hire someone for
finance we needed someone who could do
HR so we hired for function I think as
we got bigger that changed I think we've
I've seen three phases so far and I
would say we have had three different
teams I mean none of those leaders from
the first team are there the second team
are mostly not there anymore and the
third team is really where I'm at today
the first one was task oriented I think
the next one was about leading teams
like it was people who had managed
before they could lead people we were
hiring them for that experience
now I'm hiring people who can set
direction and hire other great people so
they're really talented at hiring
talented people that's something we
didn't have before and so now we've got
about four hundred people and so that as
you scale I think
changing the way your team looks has
been really important I think as a CEO
it's also changed a lot that I used to
hire for what you know I would hire for
what they were doing one at a time now
you really have to step back and think
about what does this team look like what
are the skills we have where's the
diversity of thought like how they work
so it's a little bit more it's nice it's
fun to do it that way but it's a little
bit harder to hire one at a time you've
got to think about the whole team I'll
pick a snapshot because I don't think
the size of our team right now is
probably relevant to the audience but
the organization I ran in Japan was the
team that I inherited was about eight
people contrast a little bit with what
Chris said we did a lot of hiring for
just good people
you talked about tasks and function and
we've battled back and forth about what
to do but I think is a general rule what
we've tried to do is just find the best
people that you can and point them at
the opportunity or the problem and let
him solve it and so we've done a lot of
that but there was a from the team that
I inherited when I was running the Japan
organization I turned over
three-quarters of those people and the
thing that I would look back on and say
is the the decisions that I think and
universally we've talked about this
throughout our leadership team
universally I think the things that we
regret the most is waiting too long on
replacing somebody who isn't living up
to our expectations or our standards or
the knee of the role and so that's one
of the things that from a leadership
team perspective that we've really
talked a lot about but we you know you
still tend to be a little bit slow on
the draw how does that team how did that
team look different say three years
later the the difference in and how it
looks one Chris mentioned diversity and
we really I mean we hired it's one of
the things that I kind of got excited
about
we hired a woman to run a portion of our
business and it's my belief that she is
the she runs the largest Japanese
business as a woman CEO in all of Japan
it's not a very diverse culture but that
was one of the things that we wanted was
more diverse thought because we had
these eight people who all tended to
line up or were at polar opposites and
there wasn't a lot of discussion about
how do we get to a middle ground that
was one and then the second thing when
we were higher
in great people the other thing we were
trying to achieve is how do we create a
good dynamic of trust amongst the team
so that people can disagree or pursue a
different path without somebody saying
oh that's dumb we're not going to do it
stop and then they they stop bringing up
the good idea so that they I think the
key changes were the diversity of the
team
both while all measures of diversity and
then the the trust amongst the group
thank you pick a point in time yeah yeah
for us I think the biggest challenge was
that we went into two industries in
geographies where we couldn't find the
talent that we need it because they were
underdeveloped industries so we had to
recruit people from other industries and
trying to train them in our industry
when we were actually trying to learn
the industry that was a big challenge
and that entailed you would try to
assemble find the best people that we
could train them but we had to go
through a fair amount of rotation
especially on the sales management side
which for us has always been I think the
hardest position to fail operational
directors I mean we probably went
through three or four we'll talk about
first company billboard company we
probably through three or four
operations directors and at least three
sales managers before we could find the
right one in the end we ended up finding
the right person but it was through
trial and error sometimes we hired too
quickly
far too quickly hired slowly far quickly
I mean all the all the different
variations of that of that combination
but in the end we ended up fine being
the general manager that we needed for
the business starting assailed and
promoted and actually that person stayed
with the company that's that's the team
or the leader that allowed us my partner
a night to step out of the company the
next day that we were that we had sold
the company you know we were not
required to stay on I think that's a
testament to the team that we have been
able to build but there were a lot of
permutations along the way that
individuals stayed with the acquire for
five years and then we rehired him once
her non-compete was over and he now runs
her Puerto Rico tower business I think
you know that's a again talk about
building talent and you know staying
with him and developing them and
building that trust that long-term
relationship and that that paid real
they really well for us so so let's dig
into that a little bit because it's one
thing to say well I mean you hire a
bunch of people they don't work out your
firearm you just keep going till you
have somebody good I mean that that
works but it's painful I know so what
did you learn in the billboard business
that you've used in the tower business
in building the team interviewing hiring
and building a team so yeah so obviously
a lot of things I like to say that we
still make some of the same mistakes we
just fix them faster but I think on the
on the interviewing side I think we are
now a lot more profound on the
interviewing side we do multiple
interviews multiple people everybody
trying to find out different things
about that person different settings I
think we have also gotten a lot better
at background in reference checks I
think every time many times when we look
back that someone that we've hired we
were we could go back to our notes on
the references that we checked and many
times the answer was there we just were
not paying close attention but also like
what did you what do you what can you
think of something that you missed that
later
sorry it's good thing I made the
telecommunication industry
you're funny yeah so you know this one's
actually a bit funny because one
interview I read we were for a real
estate director and I'm talking to their
boss and I you know start asking very
probing questions and she says well the
only thing that I would say he's a bit
of a Don Juan I said well you know what
I don't see anything wrong I mean not
that I fan of that but that's okay I
mean I'm not gonna judge you for that
so the reason he got fired he started
dating or assistant while he was married
well that wasn't the reason I got fired
got fired for many other reasons but you
know it created it created a really bad
culture and an environment in the office
we were only 40 people and here's this
guy sending flowers to her assistant
well everybody he was married you know
maybe you should have picked up on that
I mean that's just a full but you know
reference checking has become really
important and one of them in Brazil we
were trying to hide for real estate
similar position we interviewed the guy
it was phenomenal and then you know but
I would send out you know the classic I
would send out an email to his former
bosses and nobody responds saying that
they wanted to talk to me and I kept say
this is strange so I kept digging when I
finally got ahold of the boss basically
said listen the reason I didn't want to
talk to you was because we fired him
because we caught him you know get
paying bribes to to potential landowners
and you know for us now background
checks or reference check is we become
brutal to the point that some people
that I have called have told our
potential candidate if you have anyone
like this guy call me again for a
reference check I will not be a
reference check for you know so how
about so we'll pull back a little bit
but talk about reference checks because
that's that someone asked me about this
the other day so so talk about how you
do reference checks what role they play
I think a couple things first off I'd
say just in the hiring process in
general one of the things that I've
kind of experienced with hiring
successive management teams I think
pulling off of your point
our team has changed over as we've
scaled so at different stages in the
lifecycle of the business as you get
larger teams some of the people that you
hire just don't work out and so we have
definitely had management turnover and
it's just because I think the
individuals might not be able to scale
their talents to manage from three
people of management to thirty people
you know they just might not be able
managing lead that quick enough they
could probably get there if we give them
more time we just didn't have enough
time and so I think talent
identification is the first thing that's
changed for me is I now know what an a
player looks like in a different way
than I did when I had 12 people is there
any way to shortcut that for newer CEOs
yes I think the best way to do it is to
go find a business that's bigger and go
talk to them about what an a looks like
and actually meet that a so I I didn't
do this but I had an interesting
searcher come and interview my call
center director when they were trying to
hire a call center director and they
were like okay I can see where we're
going I may not people afford that
talent I mean I'd be able to get to that
talent but what I'm interviewing right
now is not that and I think that was a
big you know over the course of time as
you progressively hire more managerial
people the next layer up just is a
different a player than you thought you
had before on reference checks and
interview process I think I've gone
through interview process with folks in
this room before so it's pretty
regimented but my reference check is
straight out of a Stanford case study I
think which is I call after hours I want
to get a voicemail I say if you had an
exceptional experience working with
Chris please call me back the best
people I've ever hired
I get like 10 calls in the morning you
know 7 a.m. like I've talked about Chris
anytime those have been the best hires
if they don't call you back at all
I don't hire those people I mean you and
you you want to call 5 or 6 people
because somebody may be on vacation or
whatever but that's the best reference
you can do and then you develop a little
rapport on the phone with the people and
you say look this is not a witch-hunt I
just want to know if this person's gonna
fit with my culture and my team and I
the best question that I have when I'm
on the phone with somebody is you know
you've probably worked with a lot of
people like Chris
on a scale of you know one to ten you
know how do you rate Chris or was he in
the top quartile death style of people
you've worked with before generally
people don't give people 10 out of a 10
so you'll get like he was a 90% and then
you say what would Chris and needed to
do to get the extra 10% which is the
same way of saying what are Chris's
weaknesses but it just disarms a little
bit so that somebody will actually open
up and tell you great Chris how do you
think so you're so you're advising a
young or a new CEO and they're saying
okay like I'm running the business I got
I don't have to make a players and maybe
some B players maybe some C players how
do I think about developing my team two
years from now I won't have a great team
how do i what do I do
it sounds like first Andrew should do
your references because they sound like
they're fantastic I think you you you
frame the question in a way that that
helps think about it which is I always
try to think two to three years out what
I want this team to look like and work
from the end in mind right so I think
often we'd have a conversation with the
board or with investors and it's well
you really need to replace this person
and that person and change this and I
think most of you sitting in the CEO
seat go that's a lot harder than it
sounds so just like I'm gonna fire four
people and start hiring people and I
hope I can find them so start with the
end in mind work your way backwards to
you know which one do you want to work
on first where do you want to be next
and I think that's you know made a lot
of difference for us and sort of turns
it into a linear process instead of I
need to fix this whole team I think the
the second thing we've we've done is if
you're gonna keep people you got to
invest in them if you've given up on
somebody you have to move on like if
someone's on your team and you're
counting on them to be successful there
they need you to help them be successful
they're counting on you to be their
leader their coach to develop them so
I've had that happen I've made that
mistake where I've given up on somebody
and I've stopped investing in them and
it goes down the tubes in a hurry so if
people are on your team treat them as if
they're on your team be honest with them
be direct and I think you know if you're
if you're working backwards from where
you want to be you can break it down
into smaller pieces and get to the right
great team thank you Tony it's a great
topic just a couple thoughts I have
in terms of how do you figure out what
you want we've recently gone through a
process where we we say what do we need
what do we want
and then what's great and then we go
after great and I've had conversations
with our HR team that's doing the
recruiting or with outside recruiters to
say I want a great person don't don't
come back to me unless you have somebody
that's great and then define that on the
reference side we've done a couple of
interesting things that I think are
helpful one is we've created a little
bit more of a data oriented interview
process where we start with a candidate
and we have a series of questions that
we ask that begin with okay what was
your last role okay that was your last
role if I went and talked to your boss
what would your boss say and before you
answer I'd like your I'd like your
permission that later I'm gonna call
your boss it's interesting what the
candidate will tell you in that process
but then when we call to make the
reference check we're checking against
that that's one the second thing that we
do that I've tried to push our teams to
do is if if Andrews interviewing for a
job he's gonna give me five references
I'm not gonna call I'm not gonna talk to
any of those people I would do what you
do but I'd call them and say you know
give me a reference hey who else did he
work with and I would go to the second
order person because you're gonna get a
you're gonna get a different perspective
from those people and then Chris made
reference to when you when you need to
get like sorry Andrew you do what's what
do I need to be at scale I don't know
what that looks like right now and
they're I don't want to jump over your
topics but you had a question here about
boards and I would reference your board
members talk to them about I need this
role what does great look like who's
somebody that's been really good and
then have those conversations I think
that's a great resource to leverage to
learn more about building your vision of
what's possible great thank you so you
touched on retention so I'll come back
to you
Patito so how do you retain and make
sure you retain your star players you
know obviously a compensation is that
key component of it you got to pay
people right but but I we have found
that's not always that's never never
always the
the one thing that's gonna retain
someone you can pay them great but if
you don't treat them right if you don't
give them challenge if you don't give
them growth potential professionally if
you don't have an environment in the in
your company that they appreciate a
culture that they like that they fit in
if you don't I think you know we do a
lot of things you know from an emotional
standpoint right to to get greater
commitment from our people and this is
just really simple things that in the
end don't cost anything whether it's you
know congratulating them about something
in their personal lives you know whether
it's you know trying to get to know them
more of the personal level their
families you know whether it's you know
that what we call the human touch
especially in the cultures that we
operate in which are Latin cultures we
tend to be more family oriented more
emotional or and and that has worked for
us very well and it's not always about
pay pay is important certainly without a
fact everybody wants to be well
compensated but think there are other
components that many times don't have a
real cost associated with it that for us
have been really really successful we've
had very low retention I mean that's
right low turnover sorry about that I
saw some board members jump we have very
low turnover we pull the opposite
approach we just overpay everybody you
know at least 2x market and they just
seem to stay at the company it's it's
been pretty amazing I what I would add I
just think on retention for me there's
there's two key elements and then a ton
of tactics but the the key elements of
retention for me are and it's cliche but
getting the right person on the bus and
what I mean by that is in our interview
process I'm gonna I'm gonna describe
what the company does what our vision is
what our culture is like and so I'm
gonna ensure that somebody's self
selecting in to the role the jut like
the culture of the company like they
know what they're getting into and
they're kind of that's exciting and
motivating for them and then I have a
lot of dialogue around what motivates
that individual so for my direct team
it's almost a constant dialogue and they
don't maybe they don't know it all the
time but I'm always asking questions
like you know
what makes you happy at the job what are
the things that you enjoy what do you
want to develop into professionally and
the reason I'm doing that is because I'm
forming a partnership with that
individual and so retention is part of
my everyday dialogue with them hey you
did a really good job on this and it
seems to be in the direction of the
professional development that you were
looking for and I think the more you tie
those conversations together what are
your goals what do you want to achieve
and how does that relate to the business
then you can kind of line somebody up
who is already self selected into your
culture and your mission and you're
helping them to achieve what they want
which is usually in the same direction
is where the company wants you to go
that's for me the best way to retain
talent and included in those
conversations are where do you want to
be from a compensation standpoint what
skills do you want to develop you know
where do you want to be in five years
and then help them achieve that and if
you can steward them along it goes it
goes great for keeping them in the
business so this sounds like it takes a
lot of time how much time to each of you
spend on recruiting and retaining your
senior team feedback all that you know I
can do it through my one-on-ones
generally so in the beginning when I'm
on boarding it's it's a very intense
process but then this kind of retention
dialog for me is very much you know I do
one on once once a week with each of my
direct reports sometimes there's 30
minutes sometimes there now or it's I
can do it through that very easily
how about recruiting so if you took
recruiting and retaining your senior
team other than operating meetings which
sounds like you work this into what
percent of your time would you say I
color code the calendar so I actually
know so recruiting for me should be I
think recruiting and retention should be
in the fortyish percent but it's
probably in the 15 to 20 but you Tony
I was gonna give the same answer it's 40
percent of the time and I don't I'm not
as disciplined to color code my my my
calendar but I do have an inherent sense
of how much time am i investing in the
team and if I get to the end of the week
and I don't feel like I've spent at
least thirty percent of the time I feel
like I've fallen short of what I need to
do in the week and I got a backup and
reset my priorities for the next one
because everybody gets a bunch of
weekend calls yes and and and the
challenge is and I think Peter this is
part of what you're leading to is if you
do that repeatedly if it's 10%
10% 10% it will catch up to you when
it's too late like you won't get the
early warning sign that says hey the
factory is less efficient you're just
gonna have somebody who's good is gonna
show up and say I'm not getting what I
need anymore and I found something else
that I'm leaving and that it then it's
too late
and on the retention side that was one
of the things that from as a leadership
from my perspective was you learned tons
in business school about hey the value
of an existing customer is so much more
than a new customer because you have to
invest so much money to get that new
customer your team is the same way and I
would argue it's maybe even a greater
disparity between the value of an
existing good employee and whatever you
can go find in the market how about you
I would say about 30% of my time and I
do I do color code I think I stole that
from you a couple years ago in and I
kind of balance it between three things
which is time with my team recruiting
and just culture spending time with
others in the organization because I
think your team is part of it but as the
CEO it's your job to be talking to all
of the employees supporting your team's
needs with their direct reports or
others and that flexes right sometimes
I'm spending a lot of time with my team
sometimes I'm really recruiting for a
role you want to have a balance but it
does go back and forth those two where
I'm spending that time I I just want to
add on to end one thing andrew said
completely which is I think we've all
heard that adage that you know people
join companies and leave managers or
leave leaders I think if you don't do
what Andrew talked about be really
direct like just ask what motivates
people like we think sometimes we try to
figure it out like we're detectives it's
like just ask and people will tell you
what's important to them what they
dislike what they do like if you're in
that partnership with them they'll stick
with you or they'll tell you when
they're gonna leave you know at least in
retention the worst thing I think that
can happen is you have a great employee
that you think things are going great
and the next day they're like I took
another job and you're scrambling now
but if they say hey I think I might want
to do something different you can help
me find something in the organization
you can help them find something
somewhere else
and they might even help you find or
train another person and that makes your
life a company much much more successful
if you can do that thank you Chris what
you do I would say about 30 percent of
my time I don't call her code I may talk
to you see that that it's helpful I
think I would like to spend more time in
that 30 percent I would put the culture
piece that you mentioned Chris I think
that's where
importance I'm trying to always you know
there's the programmatic week weekly
meetings but also I try to do a lot of
walking around and talking to different
people at all levels of the organization
and trying to reinforce the culture many
times I do that in person many times
when some piece of news about something
that someone did at the company some
news from went that we had comes in I
try to I try to show how that's a
perfect example of one of our core
values so I try to always tight things
to our core values to reinforce our
culture over and over again and and for
us you know I'm glad culture was brought
up I think that has been a key component
of our retention when we interview
people when we talk to people what we
hear back is you know the culture that
you have here is you know we've never
experienced that culture in any of the
other companies that works let me ask a
question about that and then I'm
actually going to ask for two questions
from the audience on this topic before
we move to the next one on building a
team and on retaining a team and on
culture so how do you think about HR
strategy more broadly than just your
team you've touched on it several of you
it's not just your team you've got to
touch the rest of it or at least
interact with the rest of the
organization touching the rest of the
organization might might not work out so
well but you think about HR strategy and
your broader business strategy if at all
and we come in and I'll take a couple
questions from the audience on this
whole topic I think it's got to be
perfectly aligned I mean you can't but
what does that mean well it means
everything from you know you've got you
talked about fit and hire for the
culture right if you if you start if you
have a set of core values if you have a
very strong culture if you start hiring
people that don't fit how do you know
well you know through the interview
process you know through the background
check through the reference checking you
know you talk to I like some of the
things we do we also go beyond you know
these are the five that you gave me but
I start we start branching out to other
people I mean you don't know until you
know but you get if you know how to
interview properly if you know how to
ask the right questions if you know how
to ask the references if you go to the
right references you'll get a good feel
for the person and if you don't you're
doing something wrong but then you know
that may lead to you made it wrong hire
but but
think it starts with that if you know
what your culture is if you know the
type of person that you're looking for
you got to see if there's a fit if
there's not a fit you know pay it's not
gonna be you know pace not gonna be the
reason why you retain him or you want to
keep them there and I think you know so
it's a nation of people if you look at
your hopes of HR strategy it's hiring
it's it's rolled roll design or job
design its structure you know how are
people in different roles how does that
fit with the organization where do we
want to go clear you know clear
definition of roles goals I think you
think everything needs to be a I see
something over there sorry - no no I was
just gonna say it like a highly tactical
level like I think culture management
and this is a lot of what Witchita
saying is first you need to know what
your culture is and so that's something
that we write down you know I think most
organizations will do something like
that
off-site with management whatever it is
I've seen you know Sharan has these
beautiful you know 13 elements or
whatever it is and I think even if you
just come up with four things that
you're all aligned around great right so
start with writing down your culture
next thing you're gonna do is you're
gonna actually build questions into the
interview process around those cultural
elements so like if you valued crazy
hard work one of your interview
questions would be do you start work at
6:00 a.m. and end at midnight like that
that would be a perfect alignment if the
person says yes you're like okay I think
that might be a good fit you know so you
want to figure out those questions that
speak to the culture and then what I
what I tell folks is as we start scaling
the biggest challenge in managing that
culture is other than reinforcing those
elements and hiring the right people on
the bus it's just keeping it keeping it
going as you scale and as people are
hiring people who are hiring people and
so the easiest way to tell people what
you believe in is actually to fire for
culture so you can hire tons of people
and it shows kind of what you're looking
for but people don't really get to know
those talents until six months later if
you show what you can't put up with and
what is inconsistent with culture and
you fire for that and you don't have to
do that in a disrespectful way you can
help people move on all that kind of
stuff but that shows more about what you
value as a company and I think it starts
at the top so if you have three great
managers on your executive team and and
one who's weak that shows that you are
tolerant of weakness if you let that
person out of the organization the
organization breathes and says okay
that's consistent with my culture I know
what I'm going for
I think that's yeah thank you thank you
all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you